another Salvo in the battle to restore
Reproductive Rights the first meeting of
a task force which will explore ways in
which to restore a woman's right to
choose and protect her in the process
executive order makes sure Health Care
Providers comply with federal law so
women don't face delays or denials of
medically necessary care
in this executive order advances
research and data collection to evaluate
the impact of this reproductive Health
crisis is having on on on maternal
health and other health conditions and
outcomes
President Biden signs an executive order
directing the Secretary of Health to
advance access to reproductive health
care services and we're going to
continue forward including for example
in making sure medication abortion is
available to women throughout this
country and we won't stop
but the executive order is limited in
scope and President Biden has long
insisted that Congress needs to pass
legislation restoring the rights
embedded in Roe B Wade President Biden
says he'll support removing the
filibuster in the senate in order to
allow reproductive rights legislation to
pass by a simple majority this is
described as a nuclear option which
President Biden has generally opposed in
the past
in a possible sign of things to come
ahead of November's midterm elections
the fight to restore Reproductive Rights
was bolstered by a significant victory
at state level
voters in the conservative state of
Kansas have rejected a measure that
would have repealed the right to an
abortion that had been part of the
state's Constitution they voted no to
protect their neighbors they voted no
one changing the Constitution the
borders of Kansas sent a powerful signal
that this fall the American people will
vote to preserve and protect the right
and refuse to let them be ripped away by
politicians and my Administration has
their back the Department of Justice has
also weighed in announcing that it will
sue the state of Idaho which is one of
the many introducing an abortion ban in
the wake of the Supreme Court decision
the contention that the state is
contravening a federal law that
guarantees the right to emergency
medical treatment
Mike Hannah Al Jazeera Washington